[Música]
el mar
[Aplausos]
hola muy buenas tardes primero que todo
muy bienvenidos a nuestro centro de
extensión como vos estamos felices de
albergar este tipo de charlas que
finalmente nos permiten cuestionarnos y
nos permiten también entender asia
particularmente en este formato hacia
dónde viene el futuro de nuestra
sociedad
y qué bueno juntarnos también acá en el
dúo para poder conversar y poder
plantear alguna idea en torno a la
educación hace justamente un par de un
mes y medio atrás con mi señora fuimos
dejara las cosas nuestra hija de un año
y medio a su primer día en el jardín y
la verdad que yo creo que esta es la
primera gran experiencia que todo niño
tiene de independencia de apertura al
mundo más allá de lo que pueden hacer
sus núcleos familiares
hasta la josé en su primer día desde
aquí no sé si tenía cara de susto lo
siempre lo habían dicho que los procesos
de adaptación eran meramente complejos
yo no tenía que estar al lado el rango
cuando entró la sala nos dejó menos
pesco más llegó usted fue jugar y hasta
el día de hoy cuando la manejar el
jardín chau chau y no pesca esto sí que
está hasta el momento hace un muy buen
proceso y está bastante feliz bueno pero
por el mero mes inevitable preguntarme
acerca de la educación del futuro la
educación que los niños que hoy día
están entrando a los sistemas escolares
los niños que están entrando al jardín
los niños que están naciendo hoy día van
a tener que enfrentar en el futuro y qué
difícil pensar el futuro entendiendo que
lo más probable que ellos sean
ciudadanos del siglo 22 quien se quiera
y día podría aventurarse a saber lo que
va a pasar en nuestro mundo en 10 15 20
años más pero ellos van a ser ciudadanos
del siglo sitio y en ese sentido
si nosotros hacemos una mezcla en torno
a lo que ocurrió en las revoluciones
industriales que han ido pareja
han ido marcando de manera pareja al
mercado laboral podemos ver que entre la
primera revolución industrial y la
segunda revolución industrial han pasado
pasaron cerca de 100 años lo mismo
ocurrió entre la segunda y la tercera
revolución industrial también pasaron
cerca de señal 100 años lo cual generaba
y nosotros podemos entender que los
mercados laborales eran bastante
predecibles
eran bastante para la educación también
era bastante sencillo poder formar a las
personas entendiendo que es una persona
entraba a trabajar a una industria a un
área lo más probable es que esa se
desarrollar en ella durante toda su vida
ahora bien si este mismo ejemplo lo
pensamos desde el punto de vista el
automóvil el automóvil en sus 200 años
ha seguido la misma estructura vassallo
bajo el mismo paradigma un conductor en
una máquina arriba de una máquina que es
autosuficiente con energía limitada que
nos permite mejorar los tiempos de
traslado entre un lugar y otro
efectivamente el automóvil no ha variado
su estructura basal en los últimos 200
años pero tampoco lo ha hecho la
educación y si nosotros vemos por
ejemplo esta foto y miren esta foto de a
fines de 1800 en la una de las primeras
escuelas públicas en eeuu vean solamente
la composición de la sala de clases
a cuantos les hace ustedes no estaba un
recuerdo familiar de lo que ustedes
vivieron en la sala de clases
si vemos esto mismo en chile en 1920 que
están en las primeras fotos de un aula
en nuestro país en el instituto y en
rancagua ocurre es básicamente lo mismo
en términos generales seguramente han
cambiado los bancos y día tenemos
mobiliar un poco más moderno más
colorido por supuesto pero en términos
generales el paradigma se ha mantenido
bastante igual y es porque el mercado y
nuestra historia también no requería
humano tenido mayores cambio
si nosotros pensamos la educación en
términos generales como ha sido a lo
largo de nuestra historia principalmente
ha sido en esa capacidad que han tenido
nuestros profesores de entregarnos
información y nosotros hemos tenido que
aprender esa información principalmente
de memoria y esto porque era así no es
del todo no es del todo ilógico que haya
sido así porque el acceso a la
información antiguamente y la escasez de
la información era muchísima era muy
difícil nosotros por ejemplo hacer un
trabajo y poder dar con la respuesta
correcta si es que no teníamos acceso a
algún garito algún larousse o lo que
tenemos en torno a los 30 años a una en
carta pero aún a medida que va pasando
el tiempo esta información no se irá
actualizando teníamos que esperar un año
más para tenerla en carta 98 que ya
tener la información actualizada y el
trabajo que nos pedían básicamente en el
colegio lo que teníamos que hacer era
copiar y pegar de acá no sacábamos una
buena nota
en ese sentido la educación respondía
también a los cambios que ocurrían en el
mercado en el mercado laboral y es eso
efectivamente la escasez que ocurrió
entre nuestra información es de dónde
está la base de nuestro sistema
educativo ahora si esto lo pensamos
dentro de la etapas de nuestra vida
nosotros podemos ver que tenemos dos
grandes etapas la primera etapa
nuestra escolaridad donde vamos al
colegio después estudiamos una carrera
aprendemos conocemos desarrollamos
habilidades finalmente nos hacemos una
visión del mundo para luego en una
segunda etapa lo que hacemos
principalmente es que en base a estos
conocimientos ponerlo a disposición del
lugar donde nos toca trabajar y en base
a eso finalmente nos ganamos la vida
como les decía recientemente además este
punto se extendía por 30 a 40 años
recuerde usted lo común que era premiar
en la empresa a muchos de sus papás
mamás los tienen que ha premiado como
trabajador por 30 años de servicio 35
años de servicio lo cual era bastante
común dentro del mercado laboral
ahora no todo en el pasado tampoco ha
sido malo solo que durante el tiempo los
distintos inventos desarrollos que
también hemos escuchar otras charlas
durante el día han ido marcando el
futuro de donde estamos hoy día por
ejemplo estos dos grandes inventores
thomas edison quien inventó la ampolleta
y desarrolla la corriente continua y
nikola tesla quien tomó ese desarrollo y
potencia la corriente alterna gracias a
sus descubrimientos y sus inventos en
1800 amigos de 1800 lograron generar una
magnitud de nuevos campos laborales
infinitas que son todos los desarrollos
tecnológicos que podemos ver ahí y en
ese sentido también se generaron muchos
nuevos puestos de trabajo y muchas
industrias que a mediados de 1800 ni
siquiera podíamos imaginar que iban a
existir se dice hoy día y un poco la
premisa está en que la tecnología va a
a suplir nuestros puestos de trabajo yo
creo que no yo creo que todo lo
contrario va a potenciar y bares nuevas
herramientas pero para eso nosotros
tenemos que estar preparados si volvemos
al ejemplo las revoluciones industriales
fíjense que desde la tercera revolución
industrial hasta la cuarta revolución
industrial han pasado solamente 40 años
menos de la mitad del tiempo y lo que
pasaron en las primeras revoluciones
industriales por lo cual hoy día estamos
frente a un cambio de paradigma en
distintos rubros y en distintos mercados
que es tremendamente importante si
volvemos al ejemplo automóvil el
automóvil
yo les decía que durante 200 años no
cambió su estructura basal pero hoy día
ya vamos a ver el gran cambio de
paradigma en esta industria respecto a
lo que ocurre en términos del automóvil
y el manejo autónomo que tienen ellos
ya no estamos hablando de una persona
que va a dejar una máquina por mediante
licencia artificial los tiempos de
conducción van a ser mucho más
eficientes de lo que nosotros alguna vez
siquiera podríamos imaginar ese cambio
de paradigma es lo que no está
ocurriendo hoy día también en la
educación y ese cambio de paradigma
también es lo que está ocurriendo por
ejemplo empresas como google donde hoy
día uber dice que el problema futuro de
la empresa no es la aplicación no es el
método de pago el problema futuro de la
empresa son los conductores y una
empresa el tamaño nouvelle hoy día está
empujando muy fuertemente el desarrollo
de la conducción autónoma de los autos
entonces desde ahí viene un poco también
el cuestionamiento que tenemos que
hacernos desde la educación es decir
cómo cambiamos en conjunto con la
sociedad cómo cambia un conjunto de los
mercados y aquí tenemos un primer gran
una primera gran desafío que tenemos que
vencer también en términos de la
temporalidad
pensé en ustedes que en términos
promedio una carrera universitaria dura
5 años más o menos en promedio la
duración real en menos de 6 años
supongamos en promedio que esta carrera
tiene una vigencia de 5 años lo que
significa que desde que se creó la
carrera hasta que tenemos un alumno
egresado han pasado prácticamente 11 o
12 años de temporalidad
qué es lo que va a pasar en 11 12 años
más que lo que va pasar con los
profesionales que están entrando a la
educación superior a estudiar carreras
que son larguísimas y que lo que va a
pasar con ello el año 2032 las
competencias que van a estar estudiando
que van a aprender son las necesarias
para el desarrollo el mercado laboral
del 2030 y esto es uno de los grandes
cambios de paradigma que hoy día estamos
enfrentando desde la educación
justamente en como nosotros vamos
potenciando las distintas habilidades y
cómo vamos potenciando las nuevas
competencias que ya les voy a mencionar
en un par de minutos más acerca del
futuro del mercado del trabajo pensar
hoy día también cómo ha cambiado la
tecnología en china hace un par de meses
atrás es un experimento en donde se
trajo a 15 doctores para hacer 225
diagnósticos de personas con tumores
cerebrales y el experimento era cual era
capaz ya estos 15 autores versus un
software que es bio main que también
tenía que hacer los diagnósticos el
resultado fue que los 15 de los 15
doctores tuvieron un 67 por ciento de
asertividad los diagnósticos que
realizaron en estos tumores
187 hacer tía que tuvo el software
y mejor aún el software lo hizo entonces
lo 15 minutos
le muestro este también vídeo es un
robot que es conducido por un cirujano
que se llama da vinci y que este robot
tiene la particularidad de poder ver
aquí que actualmente opera pero tiene
una precisión tan efectiva que puede
pelar un gajo uva y fue puede volver a
suturar lo de manera perfecta sin
errores
lo cual genera y esto ya en términos de
las operaciones que está haciendo que
los tiempos de recuperación sean menores
que la eficiencia también sea mucho
mayor en términos de la duración de las
operaciones y hoy día si esto lo
mezclamos con la tecnología que de
operación rebote la telemedicina que hoy
día ya está ocurriendo doctores que
están en un lugar determinado y con
conexión 5g pueden operar a distancia
otras personas podemos ver que el
resultado ha sido tremendamente
beneficioso en términos de la
distribución de la salud en distintas
partes del mundo
en toque hace un par de meses un año y
medio atrás se inauguró el primer hotel
automatizado del mundo esto de él tenía
la particularidad de que uno cuando
llegaba el check-in era recibido por
robots que podría ser una recepcionista
o unos velociraptor
se llama h y en el español no sólo
podríamos traducir como del extraño
imagino que este por lo menos raptor
bueno la particularidad total es que era
el primer hotel automatizado tenía 100
habitaciones de las cuales solamente
necesitaban 6 humanos para poder operar
uno llegaba al
y el mesón por medio del software de
reconocimiento facial hacia el check-in
venía una máquina subía en la maleta la
máquina de compañía hasta la puerta de
tu pieza de nuevo software de
reconocimiento facial la puerta se abría
automáticamente hay una entrada y en el
fondo
disfrutaba de la estadía esto te dentro
al record guinness como el primer hotel
automatizado del mundo y la verdad que
se pensaba que iba a revolucionar la
industria hotelera a nivel mundial
pero la verdad que no y fue un desastre
y fue un desastre es un desastre porque
cuando comenzaron las interacciones
humanas cuando un pasajero empezó a
solicitar algo a estos robots los hornos
tenían la capacidad interpretar qué es
lo que quería realmente el pasajero
tanto es así que una noche al parecer
había un pasajero que roncaba muy fuerte
y cuando ya pasando uno de estos robots
por afuera la habitación el ros pensaba
que le estaba hablando y le golpeaba la
puerta al robot y le decía no te
entiendo no te entiendo no te entiendo
finalmente lo que ocurrió con este tel
es que los dueños se dieron cuenta de
que nada iba a poder reemplazar las
relaciones interpersonales en términos
de servicios y es por eso que
despidieron a más de la mitad de los 243
robots volviendo a contratar personas
que se hicieran cargo efectivamente de
la administración del hotel ya vemos que
la tecnología está avanzada para poder
automatizar todo o casi todo pero vemos
que no todos los procesos de
automatización funcionan cuando nosotros
hablamos de relaciones interpersonales
volvamos a ejemplo los doctores por
mucho que nosotros y díaz tengamos una
máquina que nos pueden explicar de
manera mucho más efectiva y más rápida
que un grupo de doctores
a usted le gustaría en caso de que
tuviese un cáncer que fuese un doctor y
le dijera usted tiene el cáncer a 34 no
se le asigna la sigla más precisa o
preferirían que un doctor con los
conocimientos la experiencia les pudiera
decir qué tipo de cáncer cuál es la
sugerencia cómo pueden abordar este tema
manera personal yo creo que todos nos
inclinamos por la segunda opción y es
ahí donde está la gran posibilidad del
ser humano y es ahí donde está una de
las grandes fortalezas que nosotros hoy
día tenemos si lo pensamos desde el
punto de vista la educación nosotros hoy
día podríamos visualizar cuatro grandes
competencias que todo el profesional del
futuro debe de tener y estas
competencias van justamente de la mano
con la primera que es la convergencia
entre nuestras capacidades y el
desarrollo tecnológico no podemos
pretender hoy día competir con una
máquina no podemos pretender hoy día que
vamos a operar o vamos a hacer una
cirugía mejor que la tecnología que ya
está disponible por tanto una de las
competencias de los profesionales del
futuro es poder entender cuáles son las
tecnologías que está a nuestro alcance y
cómo nosotros nos vamos complementando
en función de estas tecnologías
cómo vamos desarrollando nuestras
habilidades
una mejor manera y las vamos poniendo
también al servicio de nuestra de
nuestra de nuestro entorno el lugar
donde nosotros estamos trabajando
la segunda competencia dice relación con
agilidad mental y pensamiento crítico si
antes una carrera o una profesión podía
augurar entre 30 a 50 años en el mercado
laboral hoy día nosotros estamos
visualizando que una profesión no va a
durar más de 10 años porque porque
constantemente vamos a tener que estar
aprendiendo re escalando reorganizando
nuestras ideas y un poco vamos a tener
que estar conectándonos con distintas
disciplinas ya no vamos a tener una
disciplina única vamos a tener una multi
disciplina por tanto desde ya tenemos
que entender que vamos a tener que ir
estudiando a lo largo de toda nuestra
vida y para eso vamos a tener que
fortalecer las conexiones
interdisciplinarios las carreras ya hoy
día no van a hacer que una entrada por
un túnel y sales solamente por ese túnel
o ya tenemos que buscar la
complementariedad en términos de las
distintas áreas de conocimiento a las
cuales nosotros podemos enfrentarnos y
eso mismo será el que sea el beneficiado
con la temporalidad o con la
flexibilidad temporal que hay en torno a
la educación ya no tenemos que estar
sentados entre una sala de clase como en
boston o como el instituto o'higgins
recibiendo la información que un
profesor nos puede entregar
hoy día podemos estar conectados desde
nuestra casa o de nuestros teléfonos
conectados con un muy buen profesor en
europa o en eeuu aprendiendo
esos son los cambios de paradigma
soluciones que hoy día van a comenzar a
ocurrir dentro de la educación en el
corto plazo
piensan y deciden hopkins uno de los
científicos uno de los físicos más
grandes de nuestra historia
todo lo que a pesar de su discapacidad
todo lo que tuvo que aprender
reorganizar reescalar a adaptarse para
poder hacer los avances que hizo en
términos de la física y en términos por
ejemplo del estudio de los agujeros
negros tanto su capacidad de aprendizaje
que por algún motivo él participó en los
capítulos de una de las series más
famosas del último tiempo que es the big
band hero con el mensaje que estaba
tratando o porque un físico de las
características de él participan es en
esta serie seguramente porque estaba
tratando de dar un mensaje al común de
los mortales de que la física tenía que
acercarse que los descubrimientos se
tenían que acercar de una manera más
cotidiana y por eso que aquí hay una
foto que gráfica conjuntamente con ese
elenco en la participación de este de
hawking
otra de las competencias fundamentales
va a ser la creatividad y la creatividad
no entendía cómo llega capacidad o
alucinante de poder inventar algo que
hoy día no está creado sino la capacidad
de poder entender cuáles son los
problemas y empezar a buscar cuáles son
las soluciones que tenemos dentro de
nuestro entorno para dar respuesta
efectiva a los problemas que hoy día
siquiera nosotros nos podemos imaginar
jason dan que un ingeniero en espacio
aéreo tenía como misión buscar o
minimizar el tiempo los costos de puerta
hablar algo desde la tierra hasta la
estación espacial 15 s imagínense que
trasladarnos a un tornillo al espacio de
ser carísimo y lo que hizo el finalmente
durante mucho tiempo fue buscar la mejor
estructura de eficiencia de costos pero
un momento que se dio cuenta que se
estaba haciendo mal la pregunta basal no
era cómo hacer más eficiente en términos
de costos la pregunta va a salir a como
él podría crear las herramientas o el
equipamiento necesario en la misma
estación espacial y lo que hizo fue
buscó en su entorno vio que existían las
impresoras 3d hizo algunas
modificaciones y creó la primera
impresora 3 de gravedad 0 la cual está
en la estación y ss y hoy día si
necesitan un tornillo por ejemplo para
hacer algo o una cuchara basta que metan
el diseño en la máquina y la máquina lo
imprimen eso es creatividad pensar un
poco con las alternativas que nosotros
tenemos nuestro entorno cómo podemos
adaptarla a las soluciones que nos vamos
a sentar en el en el futuro
y la cuarta competencia del club
consideró que ser fundamental en el
mundo de la educación y el mundo
profesional va a ser networking y
conectividad como les decía vamos a
tener que interconectar nos dé mucho
mejor manera en términos de los
aprendizajes ya no solamente vamos a
tener una disciplina vamos a tener
múltiples disciplinas y para eso la
capacidad que tengamos de conectar con
distintas personas conectar con personas
que se desenvuelven en áreas distinta a
la nuestra y ver como yo puedo conjugar
el aprendizaje de uno como con mis
conocimientos va a ser fundamental la
educación entre pares va a ser una de
las herramientas fundamentales dentro de
lo que queda el siglo 21 en términos de
los conocimientos que estamos
desarrollando
cambia todo cambia como dice el famoso
verso y la verdad que sí y qué bueno que
nos toque a nosotros y qué bueno que nos
toque a esta generación estar en este
proceso de transición porque hoy día yo
creo que más que nunca tenemos la
oportunidad con todas las herramientas
que tenemos nuestra disposición a solo
un clic de distancia de ir generando los
conocimientos necesarios para poder
avanzar en cualquiera de las disciplinas
que ustedes se desenvuelven si tenemos
que ver manar mejor que nunca este
cambio y en la cuarta revolución
industrial básicamente ha acelerado
todos y cada uno de los procesos pero
para eso desde ya nosotros podemos subir
nuestro carro si nos proponemos que
desde hoy día saliendo del auditorio
nos proponemos que por el resto nuestras
vidas vamos a aprender día a día algo
nuevo algo que no conocíamos algo de
alguna disciplina distinta a la nuestras
áreas de estudio nos va a permitir
efectivamente ese aprendizaje diario
mantener nuestra mente ágil nuestra
mente aguda nuestra mente crítica más
nos va a permitir también conocer de
otras áreas conocer y fomentar nuestra
creatividad que nos va a permitir
avanzar en los problemas o las
soluciones que a futuro vamos a tener
como
nuestra misión hoy día es sentar las
bases del futuro una educación nuestra
misión hoy día es pensar cómo tenemos
que optimizar y mejorar la educación de
los ciudadanos del siglo 21
y también de los ciudadanos del siglo 22
que ya están naciendo si es que no
pensamos en el desarrollo de ellos es
que no pensamos en el desarrollo de las
futuras generaciones yo creo que no
tiene ningún sentido todo el desarrollo
tecnológico que estamos teniendo porque
todo lo que ya estamos desarrollando y
estamos pensando finalmente hacer para
poder mejorar el bienestar y la calidad
de vida de nuestros hijos de los hijos
nuestro hijo y nuestras familias muchas
gracias
[Música]